normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
sr.com scanner what a cool news I love
it yeah Elon Musk on advertisers
withdrawing from
X we're getting we're getting off to an
early start so earm muffs your kids go
yourself wow man by the way you can
probably not have the kids watch back
home the whole world that's why I said f
in the beginning cuz I said we're going
to play the video you need the context
the whole world will know those
advertisers that killed the company this
is what I've been saying I was saying in
2018 when the ad apocalypse happened on
YouTube I said if if Coca-Cola or insert
let's say Coca-Cola as an example I
don't know if they boycotted but let's
say they go to YouTube and say we're
going to pull our ads off because of the
brand safety issue YouTube should have
said well okay I guess we can give all
of your ad space to Pepsi instead and
they would have been like Wait no that's
really bad for our rent yeah we're going
to go give it to your principal actually
RC Cola RC Cola is getting all of your
ad space now free of charge remember
Joel Cola can we give it to Joel Cola oh
I love Joel Cola bring it back bran
clown posy guys drink let's put it in
that let's play Let's play this clip I
used to drink a jol at the South Street
Diner Serge remember Serge all right
here we go here's the clip apology tour
if you will that this had been said
online there was all of the criticism
there was advertisers leaving we talked
to Bob Iger stop you hope don't
advertise you don't want them to
advertise
no if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go
yourself yese it's like nervous laughter
look at
Zid go
yourself is he doing it okay was the
first oh you called him out hey Bob here
wow Bob Iger spoke earlier that day Bob
Iger yeah that's you think he's still in
the room actually when he's saying this
how do you
think absolutely amazing when he's like
I hope they stop you can he actually
Freez ading he actually freezes for a
second so so Andrew Sor this is a guy
you know he's CNBC but he's kind of like
their Golden Boy then he goes on this is
the New York Times Summit this is like
the Masters of the Universe of Wall
Street they're all there Elon comes in
this is where Jamie Diamond I think
earlier in the day came out and urged
want to get behind Nikki Haley they're
like hey let's get the uni party back
together you know let's let's do it guys
remember we used to run game before
Trump we're going to do that again and
and Sor was totally down and everyone
was fine with that like you can you can
be totally fine by telling people that
you want to go on a murderous Rampage
and invade the Middle East and kill
thousands of people that's cool and and
nobody bats an eye but if you tell
advertisers to f off then everybody
loses I was going to say you can you can
advocate
for attacking Russia nuclear war nuclear
war but if you say we're going to build
a wall in a Southern border well now
you're a bigot racist and must be
stopped and there's no way to afford
that we couldn't possibly afford three
billion for the wall even though we're
paying what 450 billion for all the
illegals it's billion or million uh I
think it's billion it's actually billion
it's like a factor it's like I almost
can't believe this you see Chicago
they're building the camps I loveur
they're building two c with churches no
no no no no they have big empty
industrial lots I'm mixing up stories
and in two in two areas in the south
side of Chicago they're building a
brick-and mortar migrant camp and then
they're also building a tent city well
you see that'll be perfect for once we
get in power for the mass deportations
to start because Steven Miller is going
is going to run up there himself and
actually just start shoveling them on
the back of trucks Alex Jones called
this a long time ago it's wild that
there look long
more far more uh willing to use
government power against any Target than
the right is right the right the right
is terrified of wielding power the left
has no problem whatsoever yeah well
that's right because the left is that's
what they decided governance is they
decided governance is using the
government to suppress the American
people and that's their plan right the
only difference is they'd want to put us
in there so going going back to the Elon
story I don't know if this was a
response but there's a quote from Bob
Iger I have a lot of respect for Elon
and what he has accomplished said Iger
we know that Elon is larger than life in
many respects and that his name is very
much connected to the companies he
founded or owns by him taking the
position he took in a public manner we
felt that the association was not
necessarily A positive one for us and
I'm going to go ahead and say they're
lying it's not respon he said it prior
he said it prior right and and he's
lying because so that's why he said hi
Bob they wrote right they wrote uh uh to
their shareholders this is Iger is
Disney right yeah Boby uh they wrote
that they know that their views are
misaligned with the public mhm so for
him internally to shareholders to
investors right so they know that
they're on the wrong side of all of this
and they're losing money because of it
well and that that movie wish just
totally flopped at the box office pure
communism um you know just uh what was
the the Marvels the Marvels was the
other one just absolute flop and the
books aren't doing well either so um the
actress formerly known as Paige uh that
book totally flopped after getting a
massive advance from Publishers uh Jamal
Hills book totally flopped after getting
massive Advance they sold like a couple
thousand copies there's just no market
for this crap but but what's Wild is
they they sold out what was it a
six-month supply of Michael ns' cigars
in 24 hours 24 hours yeah and and and
there he was like the the supplier
assured us this is 6 months trust us and
he's like okay and then 24 hours it's
gone that's crazy and then we wonder why
the the book about queering the Western
uh that take off it was a queer Western
H yeah that's what people are looking no
one wanted to these all had Hefty
advances it's not just like wish or the
Marvels remember Strange World or
whatever it was called mhm like the
whole plot was like a diverse group of
people with a bunch of different
identities or whatever and you're really
going to have to narrow it
down they go on to space Quest I got no
idea I'm not going to watch any of that
stuff a diverse group of friends like
that's how every single movie Pitch
starts right now what absolutely is wild
we talked about this with Jeremy boring
the other day is that like two weeks
after daily wire announces their Snow
White Disney releases a photo of Rachel
Ziegler as in the original Snow White
costume with dwarves around her with the
original Seven Dwarves they we saw the
photos of the Seven Companions I guess
they're firing what are they going to
fire all those actors just they're all
gone now like I wouldn't have been but
just all right on the face of it
wouldn't it have been really cool if
they had got Peter Dinklage and had him
play all seven of but he was the one who
said no wasn't he the one who was like
you can't hire and then there were a lot
of other people who were like limiting
us like we we don't care about this we
would love to be casting these wouldn't
that have been hilarious to have him in
you know and he's got like a different
beard or a different hair a different
hat and he like I don't know that would
just be good and I don't think anyone
would be making fun of you it's because
these are iconic characters so mythical
dwarves are are forged from the stone
inside of mountains yes like we not
insulting you bro it's like a mythical
character and the women have beards
female dwarves have beards it's like a
myth mythical thing like there's a lot
of politicians who have beards too
that's true that is is absolutely
correct but and he takes it personally I
don't know I'm wondering though I
where's he going to get the money for
operating this uh this your platform
that we all like I mean this is what El
was kind of saying which was that the
business will fail and everyone will
closely document which companies pulled
out and allowed Twitter to fail and
sorin kind of stutters and is like no no
the advertisers are going to say you
said those things and it was they
couldn't be on the platform anymore and
that's why they pulled out and and musk
responds we'll see how Earth we'll see
how Earth responds to that because
ultimately if the advertisers are
ruining something the public wants like
Twitter I mean there are a lot of
Twitter competitor X competitors out
there but nothing succeeded in replacing
them and so people will know who pulled
out
he knows what he's got Elon needs to
reach out to anheiser
Bush and go for Bud Light I'm a big Bud
Light fan by the way I'm Bud Lights the
go-to beer because of the deal with Sean
strick because UFC yeah because they
basically totally reversed course in the
exact opposite direction by doing this
so now you have Sean Strickland saying
saying things I can't repeat on YouTube
and they're subsidizing it and they're
subsidizing it so I'm like okay let's
let's push that let's let's have that be
the narrative plus who doesn't love a
good Redemption story yeah I feel like
I'm holding out they need a little bit
more Redemption from them but it's a
step in the right direction but if every
company that did some woke BS flipped
and started sponsoring people we liked
we have to accept that as a win so
you're you're not going to get like like
you're not going to get rid of anheiser
bush you know that that company's just
too powerful to ever not stop existing
so I I think and we we talked about this
on on thought crime with the show I do
with Charlie where you know it's sort of
like at what point you stop beating
right you stop beating until they
correct the behavior so if they've
overcorrected in the other Behavior then
they're okay now we have to now so
absolute vodka I think Libby you were
you were tweeting about this like they
they've gone 10 times worse than
anything that budlight ever did well no
more absolute vodka we what do we have
we have we our stuff cut off cutting off
we never bought that crap we we buy our
stuff's from Russia the real stuff yeah
real stuff vodka exactly vodka this is
what you do I thought it was fun too Co
with vodka we bought it at like the peak
of the Russia Ukraine conflict and then
the the guy at the liquor store is like
that's from Russia and I'm like I'll
take
the like I don't never saw it again I
mean I my Legend says that Russia has
the good vodka no one's no one's
actually had any I'm pretty sure really
like we have great Goose too on in The
Liquor Cabinet turn you to Bear you
Tim's going to come in with like a z I
used to buy I used to buy jela vodka
from this uh liquor store called KGB
Liquor on Essex Street in oh wow
everybody everybody drinks scotch
you like someone comes in and they're
like I'll have a drink they're they're
going for some kind of like a scotch or
a bourbon yeah nobody touches the
tequila or the Vodka what are those like
college party drinks I guess I'm like we
got good stuff you take care of our Sav
a little bit more and like I guess the
best thing ever shout out to Max
Blumenthal he went right for the malort
and he was like oh malort and I was like
are you joke are you joking he was like
no I love this stuff I was like oh wow
for those who don't know it's a Chicago
thing I would say though what Elon has
done here
he has declared a new meme War he has
declared meme Jihad on any advertizer
that's come that's what he's done he's
gone to the heart of Wall Street right
and he has now declared war on any
business that doesn't advertise on or I
should say that pulled out of X over
this so to all the meme Warriors out
there to the edge Lords to the posters
this your call the banners have been
called the beacons have been lit meme
Jihad on all of them I want all of you
sitting at home in front of your
computers with paintbrush on your
taskbar pinned to crack that open and
make the memes and when you post that
Meme I want to imagine that you Gandalf
on top of that hill at the Battle of
Helms Deep with the Riders of Rohan
storming in how did you know that I have
it
pinned I'm not even joking paintbrush yo
I literally was hitting up my boy is
still boneless the other day because
they they changed Ms paint there like a
new version and all the like original
format is off and I was like no no it's
not working it's not they're trying to
thw this uh they're trying to stop the
meme yeah they're trying to stop the Mee
so you can you can you can like downon
convert it and there's a way and and
boneless figured it out so I mean ogms
paint is like for making the memes all
of all of the drawings of characters in
The memes are drawn you know halfhazard
through Ms paint we don't need
improvements no get out of here with
that like the original like the original
always has been the two astronauts meme
that's very famously like a really crude
Ms meme like like the original original
one this this was my pitch to Elon and
he's like sort of sort of there I I was
saying he should anti- advertise perhaps
it's as simple as what Jack is saying we
should just start meming all of these
companies and insulting them and meme
Jihad Yes Meme
Crusade well days vult baby yeah it is
it is the these look Disney who do they
think they are like they they made Mulan
and thanked the security forces running
the concentration camps the weager
concentration camps in China and they're
going to get on their high horse and
insult X it's purely political spare me
your nonsense you don't care what Elon
Musk said you're playing dirty games cuz
your crackpot weirdos but I'll tell you
this when uh uh Disney put out that
statement about how they're losing they
mentioned their goals towards Environ
environment and social change quite
literally they're saying ESG has screwed
us over and it's costing all of you
money well because at the end of the day
right ESG only existed this
environmental sustainability government
uh scheme was it was all about a stock
scheme right it was never anything that
had to do with making a good product so
the idea was that if you had a good ES
score that you would score bigger
Capital with like Black Rock and
Blackstone State treat Etc so they would
come in and they would capitalize you
and then your stock would go your stock
would rise and then also you would just
gain more access to more Capital markets
more American Capital markets through
that and so again think you wanted a
better score so this is in your quot and
famously by the way they screwed over
Elon Musk um for Tesla because they gave
them a low ESG score and he's like I'm
literally the only guy in the world who
founded a company just to do electric
cars how could this is the definition of
ESG right and they got hit on diversity
um he like it's the definition of
environmentally I'm an African immigrant
who started an electric car company what
are you talking about you know how could
I possibly have a negative score and
then they hit him on diversity because
he had too many white males and so you
know he's he's declaring his like
internal Jihad against it but there's a
lot of people now looking at it saying
look we realize that this has gone way
too far because initially it was just
supposed to get your score up to help
with the stock but but then it just
slowly dominated those entire companies
it dominated their entire Workforce um
obviously with Netflix we know it's it's
turned into a meme it's turned into a
meme with Netflix where they're kind of
like leaning into it now and they're
making like like like the general
Hannibal is going to be black yeah you
know which is Denzel Washington who's a
great actor like we all love Denzel
right I don't think there's really any
Denzel attractors out there but but you
know the argument is norn Africa and
even though it's Africa he's not like a
black African
I don't have a big problem with uh Adis
elbow playing
um7 no no no no no in um in Thor oh oh
uh the watch guy the guy with the eyes
forgot his name you remember his name no
he's like an actual like nor
mythological God or whatever and I'm
like I don't have I don't have a big
issue with like anyone playing any
mythological orever me neither yeah it's
like whatever but if it's like a
historical figure historical figures are
worse I will say even with mythical
stuff like there are lots of cultures
that have myths why don't we just have
new ideas why don't we do new things
like this is what bothered me about the
The Little Mermaid thing and and Disney
pays for this right they decide that
they don't see enough diversity and
rather than saying like well what
cultures do we want to see diversity
from and what stories can we steal from
them instead they're like Hans Christian
Anderson we're doing it again except
we've just changed the skin tones and
that feels so cheap and gross that I
think ultimately it's collapsing around
them it's the same thing like when
they're making these teeny bopper
remakes of stuff you know what was it
they had one that like on Robin Hood
except it was going to be a girl and it
said in the inner city and ultimately I
don't even know if it ever got made
because people don't like it it's
transparent it's cheap it doesn't engage
them intellectually it's not really a
form of art it's barely a form of
entertainment but they're not changing
yeah but they're not just changing the
skin tone right I mean if you're just
changing skin tone that that's one thing
but you're not also not just swapping
gender when you do it that you know when
you do that that kind of thing what
you're doing is um taking stories that
have mean
that have a place in culture and
transforming them into something that is
meaningless and empty and dead so you're
taking living stories and living
narratives and you're just killing them
turning into nothing I mean that was the
thing about white right
um this is this real Tim um I just I
just saw a tweet the New York Times just
deleted the dealbook summit with Elon
from their YouTube channel no oh
excuse me what happened it says yeah
just before the show it so the obviously
this I don't know how we would track
that um if the video's not there the
video's not there how do we know it was
ever there maybe it has been archived
clips of it we do have PL no someone
someone has a a link back to it from New
York Times under New York Times no no
the Elon stuff is up on Twitter it's
CNBC is has clips of it yeah that's what
I'm saying there's clips of it still out
but apparently the whole thing was being
according to this tweet from Adda Adrian
ditman um they're saying the New York
Times took down the full event from New
York times events interesting I I'm I'm
going to stop right there you know what
probably happens is when when live you
can set live shows to not be public
after they're
done that may have just been the case
this video has been removed by the
uploader yeah that's what that's what it
would say I'm pretty sure that when when
you're setting a live stream you can set
them so that after they're done they
don't appear as videos on your channel
and it would say it's removed so it
doesn't look like they have anything
from dealbook Summit up not just I don't
know like the clips that were pulled
they were put pulled while the show was
still live I mean yeah you can't stop
the clips the clips are out but but why
would you pull it I mean I I'm pretty
sure they may have just made it to the
show when when behind the you know went
private as soon as it was done being
live that that's a common thing oh maybe
I don't know I'm just saying before I
say anything I'd like to know for sure
exactly what happened sure if they if if
it was the live stream was done and it
was on their Channel and you could watch
the archive and now it's been deleted
that means they they went and actually
removed it I mean they've got a bunch of
other live streams up but I don't know
why they would even do that because uh
yeah but when are they from one's from
eight hours ago one from it was it an
event or what is it uh summer events sum
are interviews some are just different
things yeah maybe maybe I don't know
perhaps that is the case thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang hang out with us live
Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and
become a member over at timcast.net